foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the Ken Coleman show
is my guest today as we take your
questions always remember when Ken's
around he's always going to be talking
about jobs and careers and doing work
that matters with purpose and so you got
questions about that this is your day
jump in the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five Steve
starts off this hour in New York City hi
Steve how are you
Dave how's it going better than I
deserve man what's up
oh not too much I'm excited to talk to
you this is my first time trying to call
into the show I've been listening to you
for about a year or so and um I have a
question that's why we're here how can
we help wonderful so I am on step two
I'm paying down my debt and looking
ahead to the next stages of my uh of my
my story through the baby steps here I
am an educator and by the time I retire
based on my three best years salary I
will receive a pension of 65
of my final salary of my best final
salary so when I get and I've been
investing in a 403 b account
um off and on pretty much throughout my
first 20 years of teaching good
um so my question is what when when I
get to step four and it's about
investing and stocking money away
because of
that tension that I'm going to be
receiving
where do I still go to the 15 do I do a
little bit like you know I don't want to
say do I do less but I'm not quite
exactly sure where to go when I get to
that investment piece of it right well I
would always do 15 at baby step four
even if you have a pension you're not
putting the pension in your school
system is or the government governmental
body of your municipality or the state
of New York whatever it is is putting it
in so it's not coming out of your pocket
so you can still put 15 in but and
there's two reasons for that one is I've
never had someone get to retirement and
go I've got too much money
that has never come up
sure okay and the second reason is is
that the pension's just not under your
control
and I have no idea I've not read an
article one way or the other or don't
have any insight as to how good a job
your municipality or your state is doing
managing the teacher's pension some
people do a good job at that some people
suck at it around the nation there are
some of them that are pretty unstable I
have no idea about yours one way or the
other and neither do you because you've
got zero control over it I mean you can
get some insights of people that are
criticizing it or watch dogs or whatever
on the thing but overall you have no you
don't have control what you do have
control over you need to control and
that's your savings rate in the 403
being of course we tell you to do match
first Roth second does the 403 b offer a
Roth version
um that's a good question I'm not sure
yeah pick good mutual funds with a Roth
version is there any match
no there's no math yeah that would not
be unusual most 403bs don't have a match
but uh yeah I'm putting it in good
mutual funds across the four types that
we talk about growth growth and income
aggressive growth and International
so that if this pension that you have no
control over uh struggles or Worse even
collapses uh you've got uh you know
you've got a backstop and hey big old
pile of money extra you'd probably find
something to do with it there's probably
somebody needs some help there's some
Hunger kids somewhere need to be fed so
uh won't be bad I would go ahead and
build the wealth yeah and this is a
great uh example of teachers who are
intentional and what we saw in the
largest net worth millionaire study ever
done by Ramsey Solutions and they were
in the top five uh teachers who are net
worth millionaires because of this kind
of intentionality this kind of phone
call Steve who is dedicated to a
profession that doesn't pay a whole lot
but is going to invest wisely plus we
hope the pension and all that plays out
uh but it's uh it's it's a great credit
to Steve Steve thank you for uh really
being on the front lines and working in
a profession that is increasingly uh
very tough to work in yeah yeah a lot of
people we're losing a lot of teachers
and nurses and uh and policemen uh for
for a lot of reasons out there right now
and it's uh it's leaving a shortage in
those areas number one uh career
category engineer number two accountant
number three teacher in the cad career
categories that ended up being
millionaires very interesting and those
are actual facts that's not a wish it's
not an aspiration airtight study largest
study ever done research of America's
millionaires over ten thousand of them
studied that's what we found because
every time I mention this you know some
idiot troll gets on the Internet is real
I'm a teacher not broke well yeah I get
it I understand teachers don't get paid
enough I get it I understand but but I
still found in the study that in spite
of
um you know your drama uh there are
teachers that become millionaires so
many of them that it's the third largest
category it's extraordinary yeah very
good stuff uh open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
New Jersey Jessica's calling hey Jessica
what's up
hi um so I'm a huge fan uh I love
listening to your show every day it
keeps me motivated
um
so usually my whole life revolves around
numbers
um but my husband and I have been pretty
stupid and now we're trying to get
um debt free and not davish because we
did that in the beginning and it didn't
really work so I have my whole debt
snowball laid out and I have a debt
snowball question
um I have the debt smallest to largest
my student loans is the highest it's
about 25 000 and then another one for
28.
um but when I went on their website I
noticed that they have a breakdown of
like each loan from like thousand to
three thousand five thousand do I list
them in the debt snowball that way or do
I list it as like yes I do yeah because
when you pay one of them off you don't
have the payment anymore
right okay so but if you if instead you
had a twenty thousand dollar loan
and you paid a thousand dollars off it
doesn't change your payment it doesn't
change your payment
right but when you pay off that three
thousand or thirty two hundred dollar or
whatever when that payment goes away yes
and that makes the snowball roll will
you follow me
yes and and you get to have a you get to
have a high five moment do a Snoopy
dance in the living room
you know nose up keep moving doing it
it's moving yeah okay yeah you get to
you get to feel the traction which is
the beauty of the debt snowball yeah yes
gotcha okay all right thank you so much
thank you for calling in kiddo open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five personal finance is
eighty percent Behavior yeah it's only
20 head knowledge we all kind of know
what to do we even know what Congress
should do and we keep electing the same
morons and sending them up there
maybe we ought to send some different
morons I like the thought
you know what else I love about this if
you were running a business and you have
people that work for you that were that
incompetent you'd fire their butt well
you're gonna have a chance in two weeks
a couple of weeks here yeah got a chance
to say do you have a little Celebrity
Apprentice you're fired yes you know you
know you could do that you you could do
it
you won't but you could do it
yeah I think there's a party getting
ready to get fired
uh across the old man it's gonna be
bloody bloody bloody bloody
bloody bloody this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
foreign well if you follow us on social
media you saw this past weekend in
Dallas that we had an absolute blast at
smart conference
Coleman you and I I think we're the only
ones not up there singing and uh playing
some kind of instruments other than
Rachel yeah George Rachel are
non-musical but George is what they're
shredding baloney shredding Courtney and
Eddie are up there singing along with
the band I mean these are talented
people I know but anyway and while we
were having a rock show we also had a
a smart conference where we all spoken
into every area of your life it's the
biggest and best event we do here at
Ramsey it's an all-day jam-packed event
covers every area of your life career
money mental health relationships
everything is there and we're going to
do our very first smart conference ever
here in Nashville we announced it
yesterday and we're gonna do something
different we're gonna do an entire
weekend
Friday night and all day Saturday and
this is going to be the first event we
host at our brand new Ramsey Event
Center
so you'll be the inauguration event
you're going to get commemorative
tickets oh you know I've got the
commemorative tickets for the from the
first Nashville Predators game oh yeah
sure Daniel Ramsey was a little guy many
years ago we went to that together and
I've actually got the pucks that they
handed out they're commemorative that
night someday they'll be worth nothing
they still are but uh but if they're a
nice thing to a nice movement memory and
that's nice momento no promises that
these commemorative tickets will ever
have a future value but they're going to
be very cool and you will have
participated in something very unique uh
we're gonna have music uh some fun
prizes this is Music City so you just
don't know which one of my friends might
show up particularly Friday night you
never know I'm very excited about Friday
night I I don't know I haven't even I I
haven't even asked yet so we'll just see
and right you know make it I may get a
handful of those you never know we'll
see but uh uh we'll see anyway uh smart
conference has all the Ramsay
personalities me Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz
George Campbell John deloney Christina
Ellis here's the thing we have very very
limited tickets these things are usually
six to eight thousand people the one
with six thousand people the other day
in Dallas
they're always sold out and the new
event center holds 2400.
they went on sale yesterday uh oh
so if you want to come April 14th and
15th a Friday night and a Saturday make
a Nashville weekend of a smart
conference be there for the inaugural
event at the Ramsey Event Center tickets
start as low as 79 they're going very
fast we have VIP we have a super VIP
thing that is got unbelievable benefits
look at all of it on the website you do
want to get these tickets and if you're
going to get one of the higher end
tickets they go first usually the VIP
the super VIP platinums all that kind of
stuff be sure and look for those but the
general admission and everything will be
gone very quickly because it's basically
about a fourth the size we usually do
and it's a very special event with this
being the inaugural events I I gotta say
this is not something that we prepared I
want to tell the audience that this new
event center we get to look at every day
when you drive in it's like a shining
City on the hill it overlooks our main
campus and this is going to be a special
special Gathering April 14 15. that's a
wonderful time of year in Nashville it
is spring has sprung it's a good
temperature you're not smothered in the
humidity I mean not freezing to death
you get to come make a whole week a week
and a half weekend out of it whatever
Hot Chicken in Nashville country music
Ramsey Solutions like man come in on
Friday watch the show we'll be doing the
show great we'll be doing the show here
because the event won't start until
after the show on Friday afternoon and I
got to mention uh Dr Donald Dr John
Delaney I'll probably make sure that
he's he's recording that day I'll record
let's just have a big full day out of it
love on everybody have fun I mean it's
it's a great environment and I can't
wait I got very excited when I saw the
email it's a good it's a good it's a
good program so all of this at
ramseysolutions.com events just find
Smart conference Friday and Saturday
April 14 and 15 get your tickets while
you can Mike is in Madison Wisconsin hey
Mike welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Ken appreciate you taking my
call sure what's up
yeah
um so I have been listening for about
two years uh first time caller though
and uh the reason I'm calling is that uh
currently I am on baby step four five
and six
um I'm an engineer and I heard you
talking about that before so I really
think about the numbers and as far as uh
you know becoming everyday millionaire
and whatnot
um my wife and I have one three and a
half year old son right now and we
currently pay 305 dollars a week for
daycare so that's a pretty big bite on
the budget we have no other debt besides
uh the house the mortgage and it's no
student loans no credit card debts or
anything of that sort doing great uh we
are yeah thank you uh we are floating
the idea of another child but when I do
my budgets we are about twelve hundred
dollars Surplus every month for a normal
month uh that doesn't include if you
know car needs tires or if the washing
machine you know clunks out or whatever
it may be so an infant uh daycare is
going to be more than 300 a week like my
three and a half year old is now because
he is potty trained so I'm like
struggling with the idea of cutting my
Surplus each month down to zero or even
negative
1200 to add a newborn to daycare
it sure as heck does I pay 305 a week
right now for a three and a half year
old
and you're gonna it's gonna be 1500 now
a month
uh it would be I would say it'd probably
be you know somewhere around 1300 a
month for a newborn
or a three-month-old anyway after the
journey leaves okay all right then
you're gonna have to look for um other
because you're you're now at uh you're
now paying the daycare more than you
guys make
um
that's what you're telling me
uh no 1200 a month Surplus
yeah after after bills are paid uh we
might not counting on a new baby going
to daycare
and we're not yeah we're not pregnant or
anything we're all floating the idea of
it and you know right now we're at 1200
Surplus but if we were to have their
baby you know say 10 months from now uh
and put the baby in daycare you know
it's daycare then we would be negative
so you and I are spending all this time
worrying about a hypothetical
correct okay now we're not gonna worry
about hypotheticals dude
[Laughter]
I mean it's wise to plan but you're over
analyzing and everything just calm down
you're going to be making more money
you're gonna have to find a different
day care if you literally have no money
left after paying daycare then that
means you've got too expensive a daycare
you got to do something different and
you're going to try to find a different
situation when and if you have a second
child but I don't think we need to worry
about this today that's right and I I
will just I'll just add practically uh
when When Stacy and I uh when our three
kids were younger we looked at daycare
and in the area where we lived in North
Georgia it was really really expensive
and we ran up against this thing and to
what Dave said can be done and I'll just
point out that we said well daycare is
not an option so you know we did we
started talking to everybody we knew hey
does anybody know a Grandmama who wants
to work a little bit wants to make a
little extra spending cash you trust her
she's got grandbabies she's retired and
we found the right people and so we
found daycare in the form of an awesome
Christian grandmother who came in and
took care of the kids while Stacy and I
worked and it was a fraction she was
thrilled we were thrilled where there's
a will there's a way you don't have to
just rely on what has become an enormous
expense it is admittedly very large
expense yeah yeah and so but uh I also
don't spend I'm not going to burn a
whole lot of calories on stuff that
might happen something that's correct so
we're going to work about you know when
God says to have babies have babies the
best thing you can do on the planet is
babies babies are awesome and the only
thing better than babies are grand
babies
and so um if I'd known how great
grandbabies are going to be I'd have
been nicer to their parents yeah you get
all the fun stuff and then you get to
send them home well I had Daniel's last
night and he was he was kind of having a
hard time about about uh you know uh uh
bedtime or whatever right and I actually
had this shirt on and I went to come out
here and I looked down there's baby snot
all over the side of the shirt I had to
wipe it all off before I got out here a
while ago I had to get the had to get
the damp cloth out and get the Eli snot
off there it is there we go hazards of
being Papa Dave That's it man
you know I and I can tell you this we
didn't charge them near enough for
keeping I bet she did
they got a deal
yeah you're gonna figure it out as you
go my man and you're a good man for
thinking about it you're a good dad for
planning ahead but don't plan so far
ahead that you live and worry
that's not what we're gonna do with that
good question thanks for the call this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author host of the Ken
Coleman show is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions Jennifer and
Travis are with us hey guys how are you
Dave better than we deserve I love it
brother how much have y'all paid off uh
425 000 in 12 years but we got gazelle
intense in 30 months we paid off 280
thousand dollars whoa okay and your
range of income in that 30 months now 30
months 154 000 to 220. cool and where do
y'all live Denver Colorado cool what do
you do for a living I'm a restaurant
consultant and I'm a registered nurse in
leadership
okay and so you can work all you want to
work for sure
[Laughter]
oh for sure oh my goodness wow so what
kind of debt was the 425 thousand
so we paid off our house which was the
280 000. look at that weird people and
then before that it was student loans
two cars we had solar panels credit
cards
you were just kind of normal yeah kind
of normal okay so tell me your story
what woke you up and then what got you
so intense 30 months ago
so what woke us up 30 months ago is we
finally got to baby step six oh okay uh
we became gazelle intense at that point
a little backwards but uh we really
wanted to pay our house off by the time
we hit 40. okay
um and so we you know looked what does
that look like what do we need to do to
get there and we became pretty gazelle
intense that's so weird I paid for a
house by the time you're 40. yes none of
your friends do no yeah so what was what
caused that goal to happen what made you
do that we just wanted to be weird we
wanted to be debt free we wanted to
leave a legacy and just see what God
will do in our lives and you know we
wanted to give to the kingdom on a
bigger level amen wow so when you decide
in baby step six so you've been walking
the steps and then you get gazelle yeah
so I'm really curious I want you to
unpack that for our listeners and
viewers what did that look like what
were the habits that changed the
lifestyle changes to do what you just
pulled off
yeah so first it started with um you
know creating a budget then then it
became living very minimally and
deciding what is it we really need and
um Travis learned to fix everything
around the house and cars just off of
YouTube and we didn't eat out we ate
dinners at home and had fun with the
kids at home with games and
um did you get into this at all at baby
step six and then go wait a second we
this is crazy we're living like we're
what's going on why are we doing this or
did you just have maniacal Focus the
whole time you know it really seemed
like it took forever to get past baby
step three right and then once we got
past that and got retirement set up
College set up it's like wow we're
almost there at the Finish Line let's
get this done yeah yeah so seeing the
Finish Line turns you loose really
that's pretty interesting yeah it just
so what's the house worth
um so eight hundred thousand wow how
much is in your retirement accounts I'm
a little over I think 150 000. okay so
you're at baby steps millionaire status
then are really close yes really close
way to go guys congratulations yes so
proud of y'all
feel to be completely free and 40.
Surrey it feels yeah awesome surreal
it's crazy to be here that the journey
is finally finished maybe step six wow
that part of the journey as well you
still gotta go ahead and become wealthy
and go ahead and be outrageously
generous like you said giving to the
kingdom yes put you in a position to do
that you're making serious money and uh
not a payment in the world right what's
your first big Financial thing you're
going to do now that you're 40 with no
house payment no payment of any kind
well now we're starting to redo our
house so we've really held off on that
as well
um so now we're kind of remodeling
upgrading the house what are you doing
to it
oh everything painting kitchen upgrades
kitchen yeah okay so the question is
Travis are you doing it are you gonna
pay somebody now I'm still doing it yeah
we're still doing I'm very jealous I
have to confess that you can watch
YouTube and do something productive at
home I'm worthless to Stacy it's it's
unfortunate you are definitely he's done
some crazy things
it's incredible good for you yeah wow
what do you what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
so really it's living like no one else
uh today
you've got to create a budget you've got
to get a control over your money and
just really believe in yourself in the
process and you know keep coming back
even if you get derailed because life's
gonna happen
and cross the finish line you'll do it
eventually
what caught you off guard about this
process
what was the surprise in the whole thing
I actually with my job I actually got
furloughed so being able to look and say
we had the money set aside to be able to
support ourselves through that process
but we actually were living so minimally
and we actually didn't have to dive into
that money at all which is like that eye
opener like we're doing something right
when we can just say we're living at the
right level to be able to keep driving
you know and then they brought you all
back yeah that was and pandemic stuff I
guess right yeah that was that was one
of it but we were prepared yeah uh covet
hit we already had baby step three we
were living minimally to pay off the
house so it didn't have a devastating
effect on us financially thankfully
um Dave I want to ask a question I
haven't asked in debt-free screamers on
this uh and I don't want to minimize the
effects of inflation I don't want to in
any way be insensitive the fact that
that goods and services cost more but
knowing what you all know how does
inflation when you hear things of
inflation you actually see the cost how
does it affect someone like you guys
so it doesn't affect us as much as
somebody else who is you know living
paycheck to paycheck because we do have
that extra cushion uh to get us through
that
cool good for you guys I love it well
done well done well we've got a copy of
The Total Money Makeover for you in the
live and give bundle and that'll give
you something to give away and encourage
somebody else on this journey uh the
baby steps millionaire book our latest
number one bestseller and uh that's the
next chapter in your story you're there
almost be there you may get there by the
time you get home you never know and uh
Financial Peace University membership
for a year if you haven't been through
it go through it it's got all the new
videos in it or give it away and again
encourage someone else on their Journey
all right let's bring the kiddos up and
tell us their names and ages all right
we've got Blake he's nine and then Ava
she is seven oh cute very good very good
well done guys very proud of y'all your
rock stars well done good stuff Jennifer
Travis Blake and Ava from Colorado 425
000 paid off house and everything 12
years but most of it done in the last 30
months making 154 to at 2 20. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're different
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah this is how it's done right here
you have to decide something different
has to happen otherwise you're going to
be just like everyone else out there you
know it's amazing in America how many
people are just alike got the same car
payments still got Sallie Mae in the
spare bedroom she's hanging out still
after 15 or 12 years never going to get
the house paid off always going to have
a mortgage just trying to figure out a
way to get by and have some kind of joy
for the weekend yeah and that's most
people don't be normal no these people
I'm talking to right here they're weird
that's right they paid a price to win
they said it they took a moment and said
I've had it I'm not living like this
anymore
it changes everything it really does
when you see the smiles and the weight
lifted and you see two little ones who
have an unbelievable uncapped future
because of the discipline that their mom
and Dad decided to exhibit and they're
going to learn from this later on
they've already seen it they've seen it
modeled and this is what it's about I
love that you said they paid the price
you know everybody else is miserable
everybody else is unhappy looking for
something trying to make it to the
weekend to drink their face off on
Friday night and financial peace and
peace Beyond Financial Peace is waiting
for you if you're just willing to do the
work
that's what it takes this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman and our product team our
developer team
got together a couple of years ago and
spent a bazillion hours and a lot of my
money uh developing this assessment that
is absolutely Lights Out it's called the
get clear assessment we launched the
assessment when we launched your latest
book from paycheck to purpose and uh
literally tens of thousands of people
have taken the assessment now to uh to
find out about your talent your passion
your mission and to be able to aim at
something with your career talk about
why you developed this for a second and
what it is Ken well you know the reason
I developed is because many years ago I
went through my own kind of career
crisis I was heading down One path had
been heading that direction for a while
and making progress and I had a change
of heart and it really shook me because
I went to a place of confusion as I'd
been going One Direction and I knew I
wasn't going to go that direction
anymore but what direction should I go
and that's a very intimidating thing for
people because you're thinking about
your livelihood taking care of Stacy and
the three kiddos uh you're worried about
what other people are going to say uh
because that's just who we are as humans
and so you put all that together and I
was at a place of real confusion and
then that confusion turned to
frustration and a bit of hopelessness
and as I went through life mapping and
processing it on my own with some great
men around me who had some experience
um I when I came to Ramsey Solutions I
wanted to put together a methodology
that anybody could understand to be able
to answer the question how do I discover
what I'm supposed to do with my life
what should I do with my life it's why
kids go to college every parent wants
their kid to be able to be successful
and it's a very intimidating question
and not a lot of succinct answers so as
you know for years before we started
this I I felt like it was very simple to
answer the question and this is the
sentence that I've developed that
anybody can understand if you use what
you do best to do work you love to
produce results that matter to you
you're on purpose it's that simple in
fact
that's how you know if it's a dream job
because if you use what you do best and
you're doing something you love and
you're producing results that matter
guess what you look forward to going in
to the day you're going to have a lot of
energy you're operating under tremendous
efficiency and you see tremendous
meaning in the contribution that your
work makes so Talent Plus passion plus
Mission equals purpose and here's the
even better part really nice pay
because P you're going to stand out
people are going to go they'll say
things like you were born for this or
you're a natural and so this speaks to
what you and I believe in our entire
organization that we were created to
work to do good works and so those are
the three elements and so then I said we
need to have a tool to where a person
who's not listening to the Ramsey show
or the Ken Coleman show or coming to the
smart conference could be self-assessed
and get those elements very clear and
then have a purpose statement to where
they could see at a high level this
is what I was created to do and then
have the freedom to look in the
marketplace and see well I could go here
I could do this I could do this all of
which allow me to be uniquely me and so
that was the impetus behind the tool so
from the CEO seat of course I approved
the process that you're going through to
do this and saw the updates on the
product as it was being developed and I
was just getting my keep my eyes on a
few things and that was one of them that
was happening didn't think anything more
about it and then I get an email from
you the other day hey take the
assessment yeah and I'm like dude I kind
of know what I'm supposed to do I'll
take the assessment right no I know what
I'm supposed to do he goes no I want to
see if it works on you yeah and I
thought well let's see if the stupid
thing works and so I took it and the
stupid thing works yeah it nailed it
yeah so uh can I read your do you want
to read it or are you read it all right
so so I told you all you get the three
elements Talent passion Mission now
here's what the report does you get a
detailed report you get one page that
says here are your top three hear your
mid-range talents and then here's the
stuff off quite frankly you suck at and
and it's okay because because you're not
supposed to focus much on that and so we
do that with passion stuff that Dave
loves so talent's what he's good at
passion what Dave loves to do and then
mission is what motivates Dave what
motivates Dave to come in and so here is
his statement I was created to use my
talents of persuasion instruction and
communication to perform my passions of
leading promoting and Performing to
accomplish my mission of influence by
producing change in progress now that
doesn't sound like Dave Ramsey I don't
know what does and and so what this does
not for Dave but for anybody who's a
little bit confused maybe lacking some
confidence it gives them a chance to see
themselves as the world sees them how
they are uniquely put together and that
purpose statement is a high level job
description for a couple reasons number
one for the person who's maybe a college
student or someone who's just been
wandering they can now begin to have a
North star a compass and then for
someone who's in it and starting to
wonder should I stay with it because I'm
going through a valley which happens
then what it does for them is gives them
tremendous confidence and courage to
stay and so that's what this tool does
clarity and confidence
I think I'm a simpleton every time I
take one of these things of any kind it
completely Nails me well I mean you've
answered me 40 years ago I took the disc
the disc and I came out 98 D 98 I and I
came on my handed it to my wife we had
never seen anything like these kinds of
Assessments back in those days you know
handed to her we were sitting there
talking and she's reading it
she's like yep yep yep this is what's
wrong with you what's wrong with me that
is me it's not what's wrong with me and
then she took it and she is determined
as an sc that that's the proper thing to
be and all the rest of us are wrong well
for 30 years that's not how this works
but all right right uh and then it took
the Enneagram my friend Ian cron right
oh sure and uh he like I wrote eight for
you oh yeah it's like you are the
quintessential Enneagram eight exactly
when you see a freaking autobiography
right the pictures next to it yeah and
this thing here man it got it hit it I
mean persuasion instruction
communication to lead to promote to
perform to have influence and that's
what we do here I mean that's a lot what
a lot of Ramsay does for that matter
because it comes out of the you know out
of the DNA of the leader and the founder
that's exactly right and so um yeah this
thing is it's the get clear assessment
folks
and uh how much is it you ready for this
it's only ten dollars until the end of
October so you only have a few days left
for the whole month of October we've
reduced it from thirty dollars to ten
dollars and here's what's great about it
it's digital now you can do a printout
like we did here but you're also going
to get a PDF it'll send you the download
30 page report that really goes deep and
it's very impressive I mean when you
read through it I'm just like yep yeah
yeah wonderful gift by the way you know
you've got a college kid coming out of
college trying to figure out what to do
well or somebody just husband kind of
struggling you've got friends that are
in the in between spot yeah it's like I
don't know man I thought I knew this and
I don't know anything and there's
something
um
it kind of when you don't know where you
are like that there it it dashes your
confidence yes sure it does and you
don't you don't have the uh I don't know
the energy to move forward on stuff when
you're not sure when you're unsure
here's how I talk about it if you've
ever driven in a downpour of rain and it
comes on you quickly a deluge or
tremendous fog you immediately pull the
car over you slow down first
tremendously you slow down and you pull
over why you can't see past the hood of
the car this is the same way in our work
in our career and purpose that if we're
not quite sure we're not clear on where
we're going and why we're going what do
we do we pull back and it's the
paralysis by analysis and a tool like
this uncovers who you are get the
results run them by somebody who knows
you really well get some feedback and
it'll give you that added confidence to
be uh who you were created to be well
and I'm convinced that the um the
algorithm that we put together to do
this is unbelievably accurate so yeah it
is I mean it certainly nailed me no
questions very smart people that can do
all this yeah
this gyration and you spend a lot of
time in the wordsmithing because you
knew what you wanted it to say and how
you wanted it to feel so uh check it out
the get clear assessment usually thirty
dollars at ramseysolutions.com through
the end of the month uh that will be up
until Halloween Monday right you can uh
you can get it and uh it's only ten
dollars that's like the deal of the
century for ten dollars it's just like a
novelty yeah I was very upset at uh Dave
when he said that uh I said Dave I can't
feed my kids he said shut up Coleman
we'll give it away for ten dollars no
none of that actually happened but we
what we wanted to do is we wanted to
make it uh an accessible tool for people
to try it and uh it's really about
self-awareness if you break it down this
is a tool that'll give you
self-awareness you know you gotta which
is a superpower a small team of five or
something you just buy them all one easy
what I would do you know that's exactly
right and then you could have a great
discussion with that or the if you've
got you know you want to have a fun
discussion over Thanksgiving with the
family yeah have all the grown kids take
it yep and that'll make Thanksgiving
dinner interesting yeah yeah there we go
hey it's better than talking politics
talk purpose most anything's better
that's right
that puts the sour the Ramsay show in
the books
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as Dom cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships this is a
show about you and your life Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the Ken
Coleman show is my co-host today Cindy
starts this hour in Dallas Texas hey
Cindy how are you
I'm just fine thank you
um my situation is I am 61 years old I'm
in a job I've been with this company for
12 years I want to change jobs
um if I
I need to work with people that care
about their job that come to their work
and do the work and know what they're
expected to do and do it
um my Instagram that you talked about
I'm a moral perfectionist loyal guardian
and I also did Ken Commons
assessment I'm my talent is inspection
instruction execution my passion is
leading finishing analyzing and my
mission is achievement I want to change
jobs but my friends and family are
telling me I should not because of my
age I need to stay put because it's
going to be hard for me to find a job
and I have applied for jobs and I don't
even get an interview now when I used to
get lots of interviews I mean I have
Stellar work history and
I just been stuck sure okay so before we
get into uh the applying process and
what frustrating results you're dealing
with there I'm just curious I heard some
things on you that I've heard before and
I'm just curious what you would say is
the number one and maybe two reasons why
you want to leave this company
give me the quick version
okay
um because
the people they're
um I mean they don't come to work and
it's an office it's a professional sure
business
um I mean they they call in I mean they
don't want to work I mean they sleep at
their desk all right let me ask you this
I'm a worker I know I can tell are you
leading those people or are these
co-workers well they were co-workers but
our manager left they moved me into the
management position and I asked to be
moved back because I I just couldn't I
mean I want people to Sure know what
their job is do their job be able to do
their job be capable of doing it and do
your job I get it now let's just go back
and I'm not in management anymore got it
okay now let's remove that frustration
from our conversation just for a moment
let's just put it over to the side
do you love what you're doing do you
like what you're doing forget the
frustration my work and I love our
clients all right so a couple of things
I want you to consider I'm not in any
way telling you not to look elsewhere
however
your Enneagram that you shared with us
is really at the source your wiring is
at the source of your frustration that
moralist and what's happening I know I
know and I get it I want to try to set
you free from it because you had the
opportunity to do something about it
when you were in management but you
walked away from them not getting on you
about it not judging you but you you had
as a manager theoretically if you had
supportive support above you to Fire and
get rid of some of those people or to
Mentor them and and see what motivates
them you had your chance there but now
that you're back if you want to stay
where you are
because you love the work and you're 61
and you're having a hard time looking
out you know and seeing other
opportunities you've got to get to the
point where you go I'm responsible for
my work and I am their co-worker not
their mom I am their co-worker not their
aunt I am their co-worker not their
leader and you've got to decide because
what I'm hearing from here jury and
execution that's right it's not your
call and so the source of all of your
tension and frustration is you looking
at everybody else sloughing off slacking
I get it
I get it I get the frustration it
affects it affects my work only okay all
right that was my next question how much
is it affecting your ability to do your
job now this is the question not how
much is it affecting your ability to
focus on your job because I think you're
focused on them and giving them too much
power
but how much is it affecting your
ability see that's what the giggle is
how much is it affecting your ability to
actually execute on your work
five percent ten percent
um
maybe 10. I I don't know it's just when
there's errors made I'm the one that has
to deal with our customers
okay have you taken this to your leader
to say hey I'm crushing it but I'm
having to deal with it they're afraid
they don't want to lose anybody because
we've already had
and that's what's going on right now we
have a lot of leaders right now that are
afraid to fire anybody because of this
big gap we have those aren't leaders
those are whistles that's exactly right
you can't control that so what you have
to decide here is wait a second what is
best for me Cindy
because if I love my work can I at the
age of 61 with a lot of maturity and a
lot of work ethic can I allow this stuff
to bounce off of me or is it no longer
tenable I can't do this any longer
that's what I really want to know I
think you go get a new job I think so
too but I also don't fly so walk her
through walk her through the application
well I wanted to challenge you because I
I don't think it's as bad as you're
making it out to be but here's the thing
if you got to get noticed in today's
world it's not by applying online
because even small businesses are using
softwares and and they're weeding people
out you're 61 which means you have at
least four Decades of relationships and
connections and you have got to shake
the tree you got to get out there and go
hey I'm looking to move on here's
specifically what I'm looking for and it
is relationships that will get you in
the door because they go let me tell you
about Cindy Cindy's amazing but if you
just apply and some people may see your
age they may not but you may not even
get your resume looked at so this is all
about the proximity principle I wrote
about book that details this in great
detail I'll give it to you we'll put you
we'll give it to you when we put you on
hold but this is about you leveraging
your relationship Capital do you
understand what I'm saying yes yeah I
think you have a distinct Marketplace
Advantage because you actually know how
to work and you're mature no question
you actually know how to work yeah I
mean we've got a whole group of people
out there that honestly somebody just
needs to shut their butt on fire
I mean really seriously I'm just
freaking lazy quiet quitting will get
you nothing I'm telling you man if you
NE if you aim at mediocrity and you
think uh playing Call of Duty four hours
a day while you call it while you're
supposed to be doing work from home is a
good idea you're you're going to be
nothing in your life and you're going to
deserve every bit of that yeah so you
know we if you have the ability to to
light yourself on fire to get up leave
the cave kill something drag it home you
want to be somebody you want to be great
you want some greatness in your life you
want to throw your shoulders back and
Howl at the Moon and cause some stuff to
happen like Cindy does you are an
absolute rock star in America today
that's right I mean if you actually what
she's saying is the bar is so freaking
low if you show up at work and work
while you're at work you stand out
I mean that's how easy it is out there
right now in the land of stupid
just show up at work and work while
you're at work
aim at some greatness be somebody Cindy
I think you need to get a new job I
think you work with doofuses
hold on we're going to send you a copy
of um Ken's new Ken's book proximity
principle so you can find some good
people to work with
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today it's launch week for our
brand new gazelle debit card this is the
debit card will help you spend and save
the Ramsay way the gazelle debit card
works the same as your standard debit
card with the same FDIC protections the
same fraud protection from MasterCard is
backed up by an FDIC Bank it is made for
you which means we will not feed you to
death some of these cards have more fees
on them than a French poodle Fifi Fifi
Fifi and uh check it out this doesn't so
uh we won't sell your personal
information we won't try to get debt
push on pushed on you we won't run a
commercial with sweet little people and
then try to run you into 22 debt like
Sofi we actually are just gonna
have a debit card that works and stuff
wow go to ramseysolutions.com tens of
thousands of people have already gotten
their gazelle card we just launched it
Monday it's yeah crazy I love it I'm so
proud of our team and by the way it is
the coolest looking debit card I was
gonna say something so here's all the
things that Dave just said as a reason
why you should get it I'm going to add
one more it makes you look cool when you
use it well I'm gonna go A step above
that you get a chance to talk about
financial peace and Ramsey the Ramsey
Way and how you've changed your life
I'll tell you why it looks so stinking
cool to your point that when you flash
that out you know and you in the grocery
line two three people behind you I'm
telling you people will say hey what is
that I think it really is an ambassador
card as well I would throw that on top
of all the other reasons because I've
never seen a debit card look anywhere
close to that cool I mean that gazelle
on there is he's a he's a he's a if we
were ever going to have a sports team
that would be our mascot who if we which
we're not the mascot for Financial Peace
University it's we're the gazelles
that would be our softball team name
yeah it's really cool it's our football
team we're the gazelles yeah uh
ramsaysolutions.com gazelle and you can
get started today Hannah is with us in
Detroit hey Hannah what's up
hey Dave how are you I can't believe I
got on air I'm so excited well we're
honored to have you how can we help
well I can articulate my thoughts well
but um so my situation
um is that my husband and I are
expecting our first baby in about four
weeks we I I'm the one that really runs
the finances he's the one who makes the
majority of our income I work really
hard every year to try to keep us out of
debt but once the holidays roll around I
feel like we're always starting our year
with some Consumer Debt and so through
this year I've been setting some money
aside out of his paycheck every month to
hopefully Pat our savings for when the
baby's coming and kind of pay for like
baby stuff throughout the year as well
as trying to tackle our credit card debt
and really kind of like super fund our
savings account well now I'm at a place
where
I'm just feeling really stressed out
about how to tackle baby step number two
if I should pause that step
um you know since we have our baby and
just uh stockpile cash I'm just feeling
a little bit confused on what the next
step is is this your first baby
how old are you
I am 30 and my husband is 33. cool
what's your household income
our household income is about fifty six
thousand dollars okay you're trying to
do seven things at once nesting getting
ready for a baby and none of them are
working and you're frustrated
it makes you like a normal human
[Music]
just stop it stop it just stop it just
breathe I think yeah you have job one
baby
have a baby that's your only job right
now
just calm down
don't do nothing else but have a baby
that's all I want you to do
you think you're not in charge of the
world you don't have to balance the
national debt right just have a baby
just enjoy now what we tell you to do as
far as the baby steps go during this
time is stop everything and just pile up
cash
I want to see how big a pile of cash you
can have before baby comes
okay so don't touch it don't touch don't
complicate it
just stop doing everything
and pile up cash as high as you can pile
it and don't be blowing a bunch of money
you don't need to spend seven thousand
dollars on a human that weighs two
pounds or five pounds
they don't take up that much room yeah
stay off of Amazon
okay just breathe and pile up money and
have a baby and then when baby gets home
and you got a big old pile of money then
you can start your baby steps and we use
that pile of money to go on the debt and
we'll begin to plow our way through the
dead okay how long do you think I should
pause these up to for then I want you to
pause everything until you and baby get
home from the hospital and everybody's
healthy how much money do you think as
big a pile as you can pile between now
and then
it's impossible for you to have too big
a pile of money between now and the time
you come home with baby safe now when
you come home with baby safe we're going
to push play on the baby steps okay and
we're gonna take everything but a
thousand dollars and throw it at all
your debt we're going to work to that
snowball baby step two and we're going
to go
and we're game on then okay
and then we're gonna be focused and
we're gonna be intense but right now big
pile of money
have a baby
sample
all right even though I won't be making
any income for about three months my
husband will so should I still start the
stuff can you live on your husband's
income
yes
yeah yeah I can especially with the
savings that we have already no I didn't
say you're going to use the same things
I asked if you could live on the income
you can live on his own
currently we do not live on Justice what
does he make
makes
[Music]
45
forty five thousand dollars a year how
much is your rent
um our mortgage is eight hundred fifty
dollars a month I'm not how much are
your car payments
uh just 250
. paid you can live on your income his
income
okay great you're just gonna have to
just watch what you're doing and you
don't have to have the same you don't
have to live like you're living now but
you can live on his income until you're
back to work and then we take then once
your income's coming in again we will
advance quickly through the debt
snowball and through the other things
but um and this idea that he brings home
the bacon and you fry it is a bunch of
crap
okay his job he's half of this equation
is to help make the decisions with the
money the two you need to make the
decisions together if you write the
checks that's fine you can be the
administrative CFO of the house but uh
you don't need to carry all the
responsibility by yourself he has the
responsibility of making the money and
then I have the responsibility of being
stressed out about the money uh no
that's not how this works we make
decisions together and he carries it
with you so hang on we're going to sign
you guys up for Financial Peace
University we want you to go through
that as well I just want to point out
Hannah very quickly that if your husband
is on board with this sounds like he is
and you still got a little bit of fear
even though Dave walked you through the
budget you guys can do it on his income
there's nothing keeping him from pulling
some weekends some nights right now
there's a there's a surplus of of
part-time jobs for someone who just
wants to make money for Christmas who
wants to get that emergency fund uh baby
step one filled right now is a wonderful
time and piling up cash could involve
your husband and maybe should involve
him taking on some extra work so that
you can just let the baby right just
take care of the baby in your body and
you just kind of chill he can go out and
bust it and pile up some more cash I
would be challenging him to think about
that
there you go
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five so when you are
facing a large
event that is that makes everything
unpredictable it's okay to push pause on
your baby steps pregnancy is a great
example of that a job loss is another
great example of that
um things like that then you push pause
and you get through the storm and then
you push play again and you go again
but um the the stress comes from I'm
trying to save money for the baby I'm
trying to save money for this I'm trying
to work the debt snowball I'm trying to
get ready for this I'm trying to do this
I'm trying you got too many things on
your plate and people do that all the
time and the easiest thing to do is just
uh get the old uh get the old machete
out and take some stuff out of your life
and go not doing that
not doing that not doing that
no is a complete sentence and your
anxiety level goes down every time you
say no
nope not doing that nope I'm so sorry I
love you and I can't come nope sorry
nope I think you're gonna be awesome but
I won't be there nope thanks you're
amazing no can't come
stress goes down every time you do it I
do it all the time this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality host of
the Ken Coleman show is my co-host today
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt-free stage Colin is with us hey
Colin how are you I'm better than I
deserve Dave how about you just the same
sir I've heard that before very cool
where do you live I live in Amarillo
Texas oh fun welcome to Nashville and
how much debt have you paid off I paid
off 81
756 dollars in two and a half years way
to go and your range of income during
that two and a half years I started off
at 45
000 and I ended at a hundred two
thousand dollars okay wow very cool so
what do you do for a living I'm a
medical device sales rep oh you're doing
well yes how are you good job all right
and uh 82 000 was what kind of debt so
that was all student loans whoa yes sir
Sally May did have her own place with
you wow yes sir how long you been out of
school so I've been out of school for
three years okay so you get out of
school and you say gotta get rid of
Sallie Mae absolutely Lee I just
remember living in Dallas I was a former
Collegiate athlete graduated with my
Master's Degree living you know just a
young professional perfect world
um just entering into that workplace and
I just remember sitting down after that
six months grace period and really you
know totaling up the amount and I just
have an old crap I couldn't believe it
oh crap yeah oh crap moment oh my gosh
wow so then then what did you do when
you said I don't know what you know this
is crazy what's your next step how did
you find us how did you get on the
Ramsay way so
um honestly I was just on YouTube one
day and you know I just found one of
your videos I it was somebody who paid
like a hundred thousand dollars off in
three years and I was like wow like if
they could do it then I could do it so
um that was like the biggest thing for
me is just you know you started like
January of 20. yes sir in like three
months after you start you get the
pandemic yes sir what did that do to
your plant so the pandemic was honestly
one of the best things that happened to
me because I started working from home
in Dallas and um I basically started
applying uh for the dream company that I
work for right now and I uh switched
jobs and that's when I began doing
um this is when I began doing medical
device sales and you know it was just
something that I prayed on for a long
time I've always been passionate about
what I do and uh after football it's
just I felt I felt like I didn't have a
purpose and who'd you play ball for I
played ball for West Texas A M okay yes
sir and then uh just kept preying on it
praying on it I wanted a career that you
know I was passionate about and it and
it led me there after apply in there 56
times I finally got the job there wow
you know what um I just was able to
double my income and once again like I
wake up every single day and I love my
job I love the people don't be good at
sales you don't get turned away
absolutely yeah no doesn't even register
for you emotionally no sir no no you
know and I'm not having fun with that
I'm I'm telling you like you have a an
unbelievable will focus and I'm just
curious how much you're athletic because
I want people who are not athletes yes
sir to get what's going on here uh how
did that play into your ability to to
not be deterred uh as it related to
getting the job after 56 times yes sir
and then also just buckling down and
paying off an enormous amount of debt in
a small amount of time talk about that
what did you harness absolutely I mean I
just think there's so much benefits to
being an athlete
um I tell this to all of my college
buddies you know
um because after you're done with your
career I mean it does leave you feeling
empty and a lot of the times we're so
passionate about what we do it's so
important to find a career that fulfills
you in a different way and uh for me
um I found that with my work and uh it
just gave me the ability to never take
no for an answer like you said and just
always strive every single day to be
better and I'm in a career that you know
challenged me every single day and I
love to I love to work with the people
that I'm around when you see your sales
results as a scoreboard
absolutely I mean every single day
absolutely that's what it is and I'm
part of a great team
um a team of three guys that
um one of them was a former Collegiate
athlete at my school as well so they're
stocking out this 82 was just she had
another goal to hit yeah absolutely
that's right yeah
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is when they say you
paid off her here you paid off 82 000 in
two and a half years I think the key to
getting out of debt is just
um just coming to realization that it's
not going to go away and at the end of
the day
um
to just be disciplined and you know you
want to break that family tree and you
want to you know you want to be
Financial uh financially free and you
want to live the life
15 20 years down the line but you know I
think the biggest thing is like
sacrifice now
um and a lot of the times when I tell
people my story the two words I love to
use is delay gratification
um I understood that I had a sacrifice
now for the life that I want to live 15
20 years down the line yeah and uh it's
just so difficult
um it's just not normal for people my
age to do that nowadays so
um I just really wanted to
grab the horn grab those horns and you
know just attack it by the way it's
never been normal for people of any age
there's not been a generation that had
this down yeah but but that everybody in
that generation did it right but uh wow
that's very powerful good for you man
well done well done how's it feel to be
free
it feels amazing
um I still remember I wrote my last
check it was 6 500 and I actually drove
home to El Paso to celebrate with my
family and hit that last uh click and
record it and everything like that and I
just
I kind of got teary-eyed when I did it
just uh yeah just because it was just
such a journey and there were so many
sacrifices I came with it I'm 26 years
old and 100 free way to go dude that's
the biggest win of your life that's why
you got emotional yeah I mean what was
what was one of the most disciplined
things or maybe the hard things you did
to sacrifice as a young single guy
coming out of school hey what what would
you what were you doing I mean the
biggest thing is like
um not being able to eat out
um you know not always being able to go
to social events and if I did you know I
would just kind of sit there and you
know I wouldn't eat I wouldn't drink and
uh just staying focused and uh also a
part of that too is um I had a second
job at one point and I think that was
one of the lower points of My Life
um but I understood that you know once
again like it was for a shirt short term
yeah oh way to go man what I'm proud of
you well done Colin beautiful beautiful
story very cool yeah hey we've got the
live and give bundle for you that's The
Total Money Makeover book for you to
give to somebody and encourage them like
you have been yes uh the baby steps
millionaire book which you are on your
way to that one for sure and uh and of
course the Financial Peace University
membership for a year we'll give you all
of those and use them yourself give them
away whatever whatever you need to do
that live and give bundle so very very
well done Colin beautiful job sir I love
it I love it all right Colin from
Amarillo Texas 82
000 in two and a half years making 45 to
102. count it down 26 years old he's
free let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one I'm dead free yeah foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that he didn't owe the money
and that someone else should pay off his
debt like Washington it did not occur to
him to sit and wait on
President Biden to pay off his debts it
did not occur to him because he is a
stud that's right he gets stuff done it
did not occur to him that anything
should be done except this is one more
goal in my life that needs to be knocked
down it's what occurred to him yeah and
so uh this is the difference and you
know the interesting thing about all of
those things those are not things that
are um
external virtues they are things that
you can just decide you're going to have
today I'm going to be a man I'm going to
be a woman of purpose I'm going to be a
man I'm going to be a woman of dignity
I'm going to be a man I'm going to be a
woman that's not waiting on a government
handout to make my life good I'm going
to be a man a woman that takes Life by
the throat
set your butt on fire people go be
somebody line up for greatness don't sit
around and try to figure out a way to
quiet quit because if you work here I'll
quiet fire your butt this is
unbelievable man that's not true it'll
be pretty loud time to get it done it
won't be another quiet about it nothing
quiet about it don't let the door hit
you in the butt don't be lazy I got
stuff to do there's too many people need
help for you sit around on your dadgum
assumptions we got stuff to do man this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five our question
of the day comes from blinds.com
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you miss measure or you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code Ramsey to get
the best deal today's question comes
from Selah in Colorado how do I write a
resignation letter I want to keep it
professional but companies need to be
called out on their so they can do
better in the future I love when Dave
steps in with the sound effect you could
just uh fill that in with your
imagination
um okay so let's just stick to the first
part of the question how do I write a
resignation letter I want to keep it
professional well then keep it
professional
um you know the the resignation letter
to me is is less important than the way
you handle yourself when you go in and
talk to your leader and uh you know the
advice I give to callers on the Ken
Coleman show as well as the Ramsey show
is leave the way you would want to be
left put yourself in the other person's
shoes even if it's not a great
environment even if you you feel wronged
or whatever the reality is it never does
you any favors by burning the bridge or
blowing the bridge up which we're seeing
a lot of young people do on Tick Tock
for heaven's sakes just leave with class
it's gonna follow you when you least
expect it if you don't so on the
resignation letter I don't have three
points and here's how to do it it's very
simple be professional and keep it short
and sweet and you can turn it in when
you look at your leader thank you for
the opportunity please accept my two
week notice that's it keep it simple
gratitude clarity
say like if if they cared what you
thought about them
they would have already asked you
they don't care yeah for whatever reason
because they're dumb or because you're
belligerent I don't know which right but
they don't care what you think
so you telling them to get their
blankety blank blank stuff in order is
gonna do zero good that's correct
because they don't care what you think
period that's right okay I I you know I
probably fall in that category well I
think most everyone if you're if uh you
know I quit doing exit interviews now
our HR team does exit interviews because
they want to try to find out why you're
leaving I'm not leaving
I'll be here yeah so I don't you know I
see you I I love you but I'm gonna keep
going you're not yeah and that's pretty
well the end of it that's right and you
know I don't need you throwing grenades
back in here at me as you leave it does
it does nothing except Make Me Remember
You that way that's right and the
probability or the percentage chance of
you telling them what you think about
what they need to do oh I never thought
of that I'm so glad you told me I'm so
thankful it's never gonna happen so just
just just leave yeah leave well keep it
simple and you've stayed too long
if you feel that way if you're willing
to say companies need to be called out
on their blank that is absolutely you've
stayed too long yeah you needed to you
need to either call them out on their
blank and stay and help fix their blank
um you know or you're part of the
problem now and you've become part of
the problem so yeah you do need to get
out of there just keep it brief sweet
and say see ya wouldn't want to be you
and move on you know and
um then you can smile later when you
calm down and you're gonna go well they
probably weren't as stupid as I thought
they were and so on you know yeah you
know it always cracks me up Dave when
people want to take a parting shot at
somebody and if it's so bad that you
want to leave then why aren't you happy
you're leaving you should be bubbly you
should walk in and go hey I'm leaving
today you know it's like what are we
doing the problem is social media has
raised a whole generation of activists
and everybody thinks they're a freaking
activist right you're not an activist
you're just a former employee
there's a difference I mean seriously
that's just your category you're just a
former employee that's all you are and
nobody really gives a crap what you
think they really don't that's correct
you and the three people that sit around
drink coffee with you and whine about
stuff from four years ago you're the
only ones that care you know and that's
so some of you people do this stuff and
and uh we've had it happen to us here
we've had it happen you know I've Got
Friends that run companies and and
people that do stuff and you know
they've never erected a statue to a
Critic that's true just never been done
so except that one to Roger E Roger
Ebert but um anyway Cisco and Ebert
remember that yeah oh sure actually
there's a statue oh he does I thought
you were kidding no that's I actually
said that from stage one time there's a
famous saying uh like Mark Twain or
somebody said he's never been a statue
that's correct somebody sent me a of
course they did a picture of Robert
Roger Ebert's statue good for him yeah
that's good well I mean you got to have
something to do yeah open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Jessica is in Fort Worth Texas hey
Jessica how are you
I am so good and I'm honored to talk to
both of you you too we've got the smart
conference and you were both so
inspiring Ken you really spoke to me and
thank you so much for what you do thank
you God thank you how can we help all
right so I've got an MD which I think
stands for money dummy
um
I Gotta Laugh
um we were doing pretty good my husband
and I we were working our way through
the baby steps made it to steps four
five and six and then a few months ago
we were looking to move into a different
home we bought a home that we thought
was going to be everything we wanted it
was in a great neighborhood we knew we
were going to put some money into fixing
it up and we felt okay with that then
here comes the mistake and actually we
bought it for 5.97 it appraised for 6.55
so we're like we're doing great and then
we realized that the things we wanted to
do to this house to make it into what we
wanted
it was going to cost way too much money
and it was a mistake it was it was a
mistake and we relisted the house for
what we paid for it knowing we were
going to take a loss we got no offers at
all we left it up for about almost two
months and then we pulled it and said
okay
new plan we're gonna have to fix this
thing up and either rent it out or sell
it we're in that position right now and
I had been thinking the right thing to
do is to rent it out but now I'm
thinking is we're in too deep and I
think I want to get rid of it I'm taking
some guidance on that you need to sell
it
it's not a rental it's a mistake there's
a difference
yeah it's a big can I tell you some
numbers though because in
all right we
then your uh guidelines for how much we
could buy we figured we could afford um
easily 850 000 house
um this house is so far under budget
that between that house and the one we
currently live in which we owe 265 on
we're still way under that
um and so that was kind of the
motivation like well you know we could
still pay these both off in less than
five years maybe we should stick it out
and and get it done and then have it
generate income but I want to sell it
for 100 000 under less than what you
paid for it but I would sell it
I'm not suggesting you give it away but
I think you need look five years from
today you're not going to be happy you
own this house
it's not what you bought it's not what I
would have bought as a it's not what you
bought it for it's gonna buy you bought
it it's not your plan it's a burden and
really every time you come around it it
reminds you of a mistake rather than a
than a positive thing
yes yeah I've bought stuff that I had
payments on in the past and every time I
wrote a check for it it reminded me I
was stupid I didn't like that
I have enough reminders of that because
we uh we paid off 433 000 of mostly
student loan debt uh wow
I got enough reminders of that for a
lifetime well good for you you cleaned
up a lot of stuff and I don't think
there's any reason to panic here uh and
so I'm gonna put it on the market make
sure it's shiny and shiny as it can be
to get it sold and put it at a
reasonable price and expect with these
higher interest rates in the market
slowing down for it to take longer than
it would have taken a year ago or two
years ago for sure but just uh give give
yourself some patience breathe put on
the market and let's have the plan of
getting rid of it because you don't want
to still be owning it later no and I
want to encourage you Jessica we I had
dinner we had a VIP dinner uh Friday
Night Before Our smart conference last
Saturday and I got to sit with a couple
of our Ramsey trusted real estate stars
in the Fort Worth Dallas area and they
told me both of them they said the cut
the the housing market is still strong
the difference is you're going to have
to paint it you're going to have to do
some things that we used to do you're
not going to have 40 people lining up to
take it as is so do what you got to do
you're going to be able to sell this
house and you're going to be fine yeah
just normal process of selling yeah and
make sure it's shiny yeah it's in good
shape it's going to take a few more
months it's priced properly yeah it's
going to take 90 to 120 days and just
get with one of our real estate elps and
they'll help you do every bit of that
price it properly stage it everything
so hey you're gonna be okay I've been
there myself I don't think you're nearly
as dumb as you're giving yourself credit
for I think you just made a mistake this
is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is Dom cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we take your questions at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
can
um a rare thing has occurred
um
uh two times
in the past six months uh I have been in
complete agreement with Bernie Sanders
It Isn't So Dave no I mean you got it
when it is when it is what it is it is
what it is that's right one time was
when his folks watched The Borrowed
future documentary and uh his team
reached out to us and said they wanted
to use it oh wow and uh because they're
also against the uh epic student loan
failure that's out there uh they're
probably coming to different conclusions
about the failure than we are but uh
we're at least in agreement that the
thing is a failure and they reached out
to us on that and the second time was
when I looked down at this market watch
um article that just came out where it
says the federal reserve's policy of
steep interest rate hikes is not helping
the struggling economy and is instead
hurting working Americans Senator Bernie
Sanders said I think they're hurting the
situation I think it is wrong to be
saying that the way we're going to deal
with inflation is by lowering wages and
increasing unemployment the Vermont
independent said in an interview with
NBC news's Meet the Press this is not
what we should be doing this inflation
thing is a real issue it's a global
issue and then but at a time when
working families are struggling when the
people on top are doing phenomenally
well I don't think you go after the
working people
uh Sanders also said he would not raise
interest rates any higher completely
agree Senator Bernie Sanders yeah wow I
mean this is a rarity I find myself in
agreement sometimes with people that I
am seldom in agreement with but that's
okay if they say the truth they say the
truth that's right I can line up with it
um he goes on to say some other things
of course that I don't agree with but
that's okay I mean we're
um
there is no question that uh in my mind
that the FED is using an Antiquated
monetary policy that is absolutely going
to backlash on them they're they're
going to continue to screw up this
economy rather than help it they're
trying to squash inflation that was
created by things other than an
overheated economy the economy
overheating uh you know due to too much
Prosperity God forbid uh was not what
caused this inflation that was what
caused inflation in the 70s and this is
the monetary policy that was invoked in
the 70s that's how and up into the 80s
and that's how Jimmy Carter ran interest
rates up into the 18 fixed rate for
housing
I remember trying to sell houses in
1982. 18 fixed rates for housing that
was a mortgage rate like a credit card
it's unbelievable that's what we had and
it was this very policy this very view
of monetary policy that this is how you
correct economic inflation is you it's
kind of like chemotherapy yes you try to
kill the patient yeah a different way
before the cancer gets them that's right
I mean if you if you know people or if
you've ever had chemotherapy I mean they
basically destroy your body in an effort
to destroy the cancer cells and it works
but this will work eventually but the
devastating side effects are going to be
very very real so yeah the FED is out to
lunch they're smoking crack they are
using a hammer uh they're they're
dropping an atom bomb on a piss ant here
and it's absolutely ridiculous they're
Overkill Overkill Overkill and they're
going to cause bigger problems the the
labor problem is not due to an economic
inflation it's due to the pandemic and
you bozos quarantine issues out of
Washington you disrupted the supply
chain you disrupted the labor market
and it turned into an inflationary
economy and that's what did it yeah uh
all in an effort to flatten the curve
remember when we had to flatten the
curve now we got a new curve we got to
flatten and they're getting ready to
flatten everybody with it yeah and so
now we've got mortgage interest rates of
seven percent when I blinker go there
were three percent
and uh we God forbid house prices were
doing well God forbid the housing market
was too hot
you know and uh if you let these things
burn out they burn themselves out
without going ahead and walking up in
the middle of it and just screwing
around with it Sanders is exactly right
it's going to hurt working people in an
effort to look like you're doing
something well and Jerome Powell has
said that very thing he's come out and
said on multiple occasions you can look
it up uh he has said that this is the
only way to deal with this we've got to
relieve wage pressure so that's a fancy
phrase that means they think that wages
are too high hourly wages and salaries
are absolutely high but the reality is
instead of letting the market work
itself out and yes you have some spikes
in inflation when you see wages go up
that's just the natural way it works
folks when when a target's got to hire
somebody and pay him twenty dollars an
hour and they were paying him 14 or 16
or whatever we can clap and applaud I'm
glad for that I want everybody to make
more money but Target is in the business
of profit and so they're going to then
pass the cost on to you and your loofah
is going to cost more the other factor
that has that is that has affected wage
increase is that we saw a tremendous
amount of people in the ages of 53 to
65. uh I was studying this data this
week Dave they went home they looked at
their retirement accounts and they said
we don't have to work and when the
pandemic disrupted everything they went
home and everything kind of changed they
went and said well you know what I've
got enough and they they left the
marketplace and that has created a big
gap that we see now where companies are
trying to find people and so it's up in
the ante I'm going to pay you a signing
bonus I'm gonna pay you 15 more to do
the same job and that's the reality on
the street that has helped push
inflation to a stubborn level that we
are now because supply chain is fixed we
don't see ships sitting off of Long
Beach anymore and and so Bernie's
writing saying that so Jerome Powell
saying we've got to drive unemployment
up he's saying those exact things we
want to see unemployment six six and a
half percent now how much is the other
thing though you unemployment does not
count able-bodied people who are not
looking for work that is correct
and we've got seven million men males
seven million males between the ages of
25 and 54 that are able-bodied and are
not looking for work that's correct what
are they doing
when they're interviewed they said
screens
translation
Halo and Call of Duty yeah
uh while smoking pot in their mother's
basement
and they're 32 years old we've got a a
way too large a segment of our male
population that is completely
self-selected out of the workplace and
is creating a labor shortage yeah
and you know how are these people eating
uh let me help you with this government
support yes and some of you mamas need
to throw your babies out in the streets
so they can be Cowboys
oh unbelievable that's right that's spot
on
hey let me just tell you
an eagle that doesn't leave the nest
eventually he's known as a turkey that's
how this works so
um this is what's going on in the
economy boys and girls it's real stuff
out there we have a work ethic crisis in
America
for sure without a doubt we got people
aiming at mediocrity instead of trying
to be somebody
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
of the book from paycheck purpose
how many of you are listening to the
show today wish you'd learned how to
handle money the right way when you were
in high school yeah me too think of all
the money mistakes that would have never
happened well parents even though you
can't go back in time you can make sure
your teens learn how to handle their
money now while they're in school like
how to budget how to save how to spend
wisely how to avoid debt foundations and
personal finance is the homeschool
curriculum we put together here at
Ramsey it'll give your teams the tools
they need to win with money to pay cash
for college to stay out of debt and it's
not just another homeschool curriculum
it is a life-changing course that will
completely transform how your teens
think about money so give your teens the
money skills they need now for the rest
of their lives foundations in personal
finance homeschool curriculum find out
more at ramseysolutions.com slash
homeschool Annie is with us Annie is in
Raleigh North Carolina hi Annie welcome
welcome to the Ramsay show hi y'all
thank you for taking the call sure
what's up
my uh my father-in-law's family owned a
property that
that is demolished because it had fallen
into disrepair
we thought that the property would sit
there forever because it's not in a
desirable neighborhood but then we
received a property sale agreement for
the property
saying they would pay us about five
thousand dollars for the property
after they pay all the liens escrow
taxes recording fees all of that we
thought that that sounded like a great
deal but they haven't done a title
search we don't have the money to do a
title search unless we use our emergency
fund
so we think that this is going to fall
through but we don't know if we need to
do a title search and try to resolve
this property with the other heirs
there's no money that we know of to be
made off of it because of the
liens and taxes that have are backed
taxes at this point we just don't know
what to do we don't want to use our
emergency fund but we
it's not your responsibility it's not
your money it's not your responsibility
okay it's not your property
okay is it
no it is still in the grandmother's name
yeah well but I'm saying and she didn't
have a will
right it has not gone through probate
okay when did she die
2002. good Lord
okay and how many errors does she have
uh my husband would be the one on this
side and then there is a son on the
other side that is still loving
there's only two people
right because the other son is still
alive the
property owner's son is still alive on
one side and then he has all of his kids
and then my husband was the only
surviving child of
the owners oh okay
family so there's only two surviving
child right the his his brothers and
sisters that passed a day of kids
he had a brother that passed and in 2009
and never had children okay all right
then yeah then those are the two errors
it sounds like so both of them ought to
be able to get together and sign a deed
shouldn't they
but doesn't have to go through probate
to
uh ask a title company in your state I'm
not sure
okay 2002 if you can just uh both of you
sign affidavits that you're the only
heirs and you sign it
um not sure it'll be good enough for
title policy but uh but you can probably
transfer the title depending on where
your state I don't know your State's
laws that well so they are advertising
this property for sale the company that
reached out to us how are they
advertising it for sale they don't own
it
I don't know but I accidentally found it
on Zillow one day yeah well you need to
call them and tell them not to advertise
them for sale since they don't own it
okay if they want to buy and close on it
then they can put it up for sale
but we shouldn't use our emergency funds
no you should not use any money
you should be just let the buyer pay the
cost to have the title searched and have
them place it with a title company and
if the title company can tell you
whether you've got to run it through
probate and if they want to run it
through probate they can pay the cost
for that it's not worth it it's not
worth anything it's not putting money in
your pocket
okay
right and we are
we are living paycheck to paycheck
except for are very small do not pay any
money for a transaction here
okay the only thing you want to do is
have your husband and his his uh Uncle I
guess it is or whatever it is sign a
deed and get money that's the only thing
we want to do here there's no other
transaction there's no other calories
but let the people know they don't need
to be advertising the property unless uh
unless they want to close on it and they
need to go to the title company and the
title company can tell them whether they
need to go through probate or not
okay but you're yeah they should stop
they don't need to be advertising
something they don't know these Goobs
but um it sounds like it's more trouble
than it's worth I think I just forget
about it and move on with my life it
doesn't sound like by the time you
finish all this you're going to end up
with anything except a bunch of worry
and headaches do not write any checks
under any circumstances for this
property it is not your problem it's
someone else's problem that's simple
Virginia is with us in Orlando hi
Virginia welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you so much for taking the call
sure what's up I I well I called back in
March and got through and had asked some
advice about paying down my mortgage
making a rather large fifty thousand
dollar I paid out on my mortgage
and after some discussion uh we all came
to the realization that was a good idea
so I did
and I've still been aggressively paying
on my mortgage
while putting money towards my emergency
funding savings
and then last week I found out that my
position at work is being eliminated
so I have a couple of options
I had planned on working another seven
to ten years continuing to build up
retirement
so I can look for another position I've
got
about 40 days to do that yep or
I can take the severance package
I've been there over 35 years I can take
the severance package and early
retirement
utilize my retirement benefits for
insurance Etc
um
and I do have a 401k through work as
well as
a small beneficiary Ira how old are you
just
um I'm 55. okay you can't access the
401K
um I don't know why you can't take
retirement package Severance and go get
a job
well I can't go get a
so I think I can take the severance
package in retirement yeah
together
um I do have a pension
between my employer and I think I can
access that yep
um and I ran just the estimator on it if
I took it as a single life annuity it
would be 1400 and change a month I would
take it as a lump sum and roll it into
an IRA and not take it and go get a job
ah
it's both hands well and that was going
to be my that was going to be my
question because my first option is the
the monthly option nope or I can take
the lump sum which is like 300 and
change yep roll that into an IRA and
keep working
yep
you weren't ready to be out to pasture
and I'm not putting you out to pasture
and this is Virginia this is known as a
win-win if you look like a shining bonus
into the next deal
well but it's going to be a highly tax
signing bonus
because it's being paid as a lump sum
what the retirement or the severance
just Discover it well good take it
so it's what signing bonuses are taxable
yeah I'd go get a job kiddo no question
what did you do yeah this fast forward
is everything yeah everything paying off
the house faster not a big bunch of
money and
extra stuff extra money oh darn
me again please
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book from
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
death free stage Monique is with us hey
Monique how are you I'm good and
yourself better than I deserve where do
you live I live in Norfolk Virginia
welcome to Nashville and here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off I paid off seventy six thousand four
hundred and thirty dollars in 21 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time I'm about 60 to 70.
good for you what do you do for a living
I'm a realtor in Air Force reservist oh
thanks for your service thanks for
yourself and uh what kind of uh that was
the 76 000. it was my house all right
paid for house yes sir you're weird yes
sir I love you awesome well done kiddo
what's the house worth the house is
worth now about two hundred and thirty
thousand wow how's that feel it feels
fantastic I mean like you got no
payments I don't I remember when I
started the seven baby steps back in 07
and I was like getting out of debt and I
never even thought that I even wanted to
own a house and now like I own the house
and no one can take my house or my car
if something goes wrong wow
your family has to be looking at you
like wow I hope so
[Laughter]
congratulations thank you how old are
you 41. well done well done young lady
very well done and a paid for stinking
house what's the house worth you said
about 2 30. about 2 30. all right very
good very good all right tell us the
story what happened what got you started
on all this Ramsey stuff so in 2007 my
co-worker I had just started a job at
American Airlines and she said that you
said that I shouldn't invest my money
unless I if I unless I didn't have any
debt and I thought it was crazy so I
went home I read the book that weekend
and I was like well I guess I can give
it a try for a year and 15 years later
I've made my way all the way through the
baby steps love it yeah that's crazy let
me go read and see if this guy really
said that and you're like well no he
actually did say it I think it makes
sense you know and 15 years later here
we are yeah 41 years old with a paid for
a house and I just stuck with that I was
in the U.S Airways American Airlines
layoff and then I had two more layoffs
within a span of four years and I never
had a financial crisis at all wow
wow wow that really you're amazing very
very very well done how much you got in
retirement
um I have my total net worth now is
about 400
000. good for you wow you are on your
way to Baby Steps Millionaire Next Stop
I hope
well done 15 years and here we are
that's exactly that's amazing and going
through layoff after layoff and still
pulling it up pulling it out well done
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you're 41 years
old with a paid for house I would say
having the budget and using the budget
and never stopping like no matter what
if it's an unemployment check if it's a
severance check no matter where the
money comes no matter how big or small
always use a budget and then
um just make the payments like I don't
care if it's two dollars or three
dollars like it doesn't matter every
little bit counts
well first I got to say I grew up in the
757 so you're representing I love that
Hampton Roads Virginia awesome stuff
um I I'm curious to know what it was
like for you when you first started out
so you read the book and you go okay I
want to do this and you get into this
I'm curious from your journey because
you've been at it a long time yeah when
you hit maybe some patches of
discouragement is this thing ever going
to work out or maybe you were
intimidated I'm just curious what your
story was maybe early on and what you
did to get over that hump and get that
momentum going well generally speaking
I'm pretty driven so when I found out
the book I had just graduated from my
MBA and started working and I had moved
to a new city so I hadn't really had any
Roots anywhere
um so I didn't have to like necessarily
stop doing a lot and so what I focused
on was making sure that the money got to
the payments but then just doing like
free stuff the biggest challenges are
probably like friends who thought it was
weird
um and wanted me to do do things or
whatnot so I wasn't in a point where I
was like in a dire situation I was like
kind of in a good situation to start new
habits uh so that was like pretty easy
um the house was a little tough because
in the beginning
it wasn't as like exciting to pay it off
but then you know covid hit and I wasn't
sure what would happen with real estate
because I was a fairly new agent at the
time and I was just like on the
four-year anniversary I was like I'm
gonna pay this off by next year I didn't
make it the next year but I made it
within two wow so that was like the
slowest challenging part was the first
four years of paying the house wow yeah
because you don't feel the progress
right yeah and but covet gave you a
little urgency and kicked it in 100 I
realized that I could my basic living
expenses were only 1600 a month I was
like I could work at Chick-fil-A and
make that so yeah so I got rid of the
the mortgage how long have you been in
the Air Force Reserves
um it's about nine years this month okay
wow
well done very well done okay the secret
again to getting out of debt is what
having a budget having a budget to it
and using it over and over no matter
what it is always applying every dollar
no matter what it is every dollar that
comes in no matter where it comes from
Severance or unemployment whatever it is
I heard you say that yep and then
yep yep keep sending that extra two
dollars that extra ten dollars that
because you just it's part of being in
the Rhythm staying on the plan staying
on the plan staying on the plan well
done thank you excellent excellent
excellent job wow so you feel great now
yeah I can do whatever I want now what's
the first big thing you're gonna do now
well the first thing I did was I bought
a coach tote and I signed up for Orange
Theory nice okay all right Gotta Have A
Nice handbag yes okay that's a good
celebration right there well done well
done and now you can continue to do
anything you don't have any payments you
got lots of lots of margin now I do lots
of things you can do so well done hey we
got a live and give bundle for you The
Total Money Makeover book and you'll be
able to give that to somebody maybe
they'll read it through like you did and
maybe not and maybe uh maybe we can
break their stubbornness too so we'll
hand it off to that I hope so and uh the
baby steps millionaires book the latest
number one bestseller because that's
your next chapter for sure and I
one-year membership to Financial Peace
University as well as part of the live
and give bundle so we'll get that to you
in a few minutes congratulations very
well done thank you Monique from Norfolk
Virginia 76 000 paid off house and
everything she's weird did it in 21
months making 60 to 70
000. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one I'm debt free
oh
this is how it's done boys and girls
this is how it's done
so uh Austin we got that video handy
that we were talking about earlier yeah
I think that absolutely applies here so
we're always telling you yeah that the
tortoise beats the hair yes and so she
starts this 15 years every little bit
every little bit every little bit and so
those of you watching on YouTube you're
going to be able to see the uh tortoise
uh actually beating the hair this isn't
actually a children's
or Dave Ramsey preaching about it as a
metaphor it's actually happened well
yeah it does I mean it I I suspect that
most hairs uh really can't keep their
eye on the ball and uh they get they get
you know they get sidetracked by
everything flashy can you fire it or not
not gonna make it it's coming up okay
because you just got 30 seconds
okay so of course we know the the esop's
Fable the tortoise and the hair that the
hair is distracted adds all over the
place he's stopping to look at every
little thing he's on Amazon Prime he's
you know he's doing everything and the
Tortoise is ugly and just keeps on
until they get there you just keep
pushing through keep pushing through we
even sell a version of it okay there it
is there it is this is an actual race
this is an actual race between the hair
and you can see what happens see we can
look there it comes out fast getting
distracted comes out fast but stops
becomes enamored trying to uh please the
crowd wants to look around at the people
yeah tortoises my favorite part the gal
tries to get the rabbit's attention come
on buddy does it buddy and there it is
the tortoise crosses the Finish Line
first once again proving the Fable to be
true hey this is how it works this is
how it works boys and girls we don't
sell microwaves around here we are in
the crock pot business this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day James 1 2 and 3
consider it pure joy in my brothers and
sisters whenever you face Trials of many
kinds because you know that the testing
of your faith produces perseverance
Chris Pratt says when life gives you
lemons make lemonade I read that on one
can of lemonade
I like to think it applies to life yeah
that's pretty good I read that on the
can of laminate I wonder how that
happened open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Paul is
with us in Des Moines hi Paul how are
you
hey I'm good Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up in your world
um I just had a question for you
um real quick story before that is when
I was going through baby step two I had
about four or five credit cards and I
would pay one off and call it up and
close it and pay one off and call it up
and close it they would always give me
resistance for closing the credit cards
and uh one of the guys eventually I just
dropped her name and said the reason I'm
closing it is I'm on the Dave Ramsey
plan and he said I know who the Steve
Ramsey is that you speak of and I know
that there's nothing I can say that will
change your mind
one way to shut them down that's great
okay
so my question is
um I'm on baby step 3B
um
I put an offer in for a house to buy the
house in cash for right around like two
hundred thousand dollars and they might
I'm not they haven't accepted it it was
just today but they might come back with
like a counter offer and was wondering
that's mostly all the uh cash I have but
I have a little bit of an emergency fund
and really my question is if I have like
a paid off house
what sort of emergency fund do I need if
my expenses are really low like if
they're like 800 a month it seems like
maybe 4 800 is a little bit low for an
emergency fund as a homeowner so just
yeah because you know we always say
three to six months of expenses as a
guideline
um but I you know you're doing something
very amazing there how old are you
36 and you're paying cash for a house
with 200 Grand or so
trying to yeah yeah I really wouldn't
want to get under 10 000.
because emergencies in your situation
are going to take the form uh of
something like a transmission going out
on a car or uh some kind of Crisis
happens and you need to fly across the
country to be with family or something
like that they're going to take that
kind of form uh they're not really going
to take the form of oh I've got to
support myself because I lost my job
because in that case you you know your
your Baseline is so low you can go
you know uh Uber Eats and survive right
sure so it's more going to be a lump sum
comes at you of some kind of heat and
air system goes out five grand or
something like that that's uh that
catches you off guard an emergency
obviously is an unexpected event and so
I I you know I would say a minimum in a
situation like that's going to be 10
grand what do you make a year
um roughly 60 yeah it's kind of frequent
so it's kind of up and down month by
month I mean you you could cheat down a
little bit if you want to and you know
I'm going to close on the house and have
seven Grand in there or something like
that but no I'm not going to use the uh
you know three to six month of expenses
when your expenses are only 800 bucks I
think your life has more risk to it than
that in terms of covering it with an
emergency fund is that logical
yeah yeah that totally makes sense that
that feels comfortable to me I just
wanted to yeah how much have you got no
savings total uh 2 15. okay so that
gives you 205 so you ain't got much
wiggle room on this negotiation then
yeah
yeah okay all right cool that'd be
interesting thanks for taking my call
yeah I mean the market has slowed down
and you're a cash buyer no contingencies
on mortgages
um you know I just hold stance and if
this doesn't work I'd just say it I'm
gonna get the next house I'm gonna find
one I can buy for for that and uh the
more the market slows down the more
you're gonna be able to slip up on a
deal maybe uh for the first time in
really three years
yeah you don't have a bunch of people
lining up anymore you know and he is
very attractive as a buyer yeah it's
pretty cool Paul very proud of you
that's a very neat place to be you know
we don't hear those stories very often
36 years old and I've saved up 200 000
to find a house and pay cash for it in
Des Moines Iowa you can get a decent
house for 200 too I mean it's not a
shanty right you know Isaac is with us
Isaac's in New Jersey how are you Isaac
hey Dave how are you better than we
deserve sir how can we help
yeah so the reason I'm calling today um
my wife and I got married
um in last July
um congratulations I'm 22 years old what
was that congratulations
thank you yeah so I'm 22 years old I
make uh 65 000 a year
um I have no debt other than what we
took out we used credit cards to pay for
the wedding
um I own a house I owe 132 000 left on
my house
um and so I owe six thousand dollars
left on the One credit card my question
is
um the credit card is at 21 interest
rate so I was wondering if I should
um instead of keep paying the
credit card payment at the 21 because
every time I feel like I make a payment
and then I get an interest charge and it
keeps going in a circle I was wondering
if I should uh go to a credit union and
take out a personal loan
what does your wife make
uh she's in college so I'm cash flowing
her College
oh
okay
um well income so she doesn't she
doesn't work at all
uh she works part-time
um but you know making probably about
five grand a year
not much work okay
no okay uh she's going to be uh she's in
going to medical school so
you're going to become a doctor
and how are we paying for that
uh cash flow so so actually this year
with financial aid
um because my income
um or her this this semester was paid
for
either financial aid but then after that
uh you know I'm going to be cash flowing
it okay
all right
um well the the good news is you only
owe six thousand dollars and uh the bad
news is you need to work your complete
tail end off for the next uh two months
three months four months and get paid a
thousand dollars a month on it and be
done with it interest rates not the
problem intensity and focus is the issue
and so if you were going to keep the
loan for five years yeah we would
refinance it and get a lower interest
rate but that's not healthy for you you
need to place scissors across that card
chop it up have plastic surgery have a
plasticity and uh then step in there and
take an extra job or six live on nothing
all of you guys just roll up your
sleeves and punch that credit card in
the nose and if you pay a thousand
dollars a month it's gone in six months
and then the interest rate doesn't
matter mathematically and the reason
it's killing you is you're making little
bitty payments and you got a big old
interest
but when you start putting thousand
fifteen hundred bucks a month on it it's
going to go away really fast yeah it's
absolutely the advice and right now is
the time to do it this is all about
hustle and getting any kind of every job
possible and see how quickly
yeah especially part-time jobs there's a
dearth of part-time jobs that can pay
very very well 15 16 20 hours an hour I
mean and you could knock out six grand
in credit card debt fast yeah and she
could too yeah I challenge both of you
as an older brother and go we could
probably both work several more hours
and get this thing done quickly yes fast
fast fast super fast that's the answer
and then the interest rate at that point
doesn't matter if you're going to keep
the loan five years you're not following
what we teach and yes you would go to
the credit union and get a new loan but
you can't borrow your way out of debt
and we don't want to keep a credit card
loan around like it's a pet I want to
get rid of it it's evil it's a disaster
and it was a mistake and so yeah let's
get the mess cleaned up as fast as
possible and never go back there again
never again you got to draw a line in
the sand so hang on I'm going to send
you a belated wedding gift it's called
The Total Money Makeover it's a book
that'll show you guys how to get started
and how to handle money how to get out
of debt and how to build wealth so you
hang on I'll send you a copy of it to
say happy wedding day a little bit late
so well done Ken good job today thank
you sir well done well in Austin and
Zach and Andrew and everybody in the
booth well done guys excellent work
hi I'm Dave Ramsey your host will be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there is ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign